My name is Vinograda Viktor I am the owner of a
production company
You were on the Maidan the first day after the
legendary beating of students by a golden eagle
after that we spent a lot of
time there I think the level of
conditionally self-awareness of everyone has changed,
meaning the individuality of the Ukrainian as
such, let's take the average me, for example, the
level of freedom to assure understanding of
what  we’ll call ourselves things around ourselves, it
’s not cattle
and not a lot of sulfur, I knew people who before the
Maidan and after the Maidan,
well, they were completely different than at the
time they were conditionally dry, callous,
cynical, self-contained people who,
after these events, began to drag kilograms to the
Maidan  food, money, clothes,
medicines, and everything else
, unfortunately, now I see that after a
while, due to common dogs in the country,
including this, the
percentage of disappointment is also growing little by little